one of the South's Best Kept Secrets
Gulf Shores Alabama is a Haven for
fishermen
beachgoers
and sharks
[Music]
more attacks occur along these Shores
than anywhere else in the state what
makes this area a shark attack hotspot
answer is a warning that vacationers
everywhere should he
started coming to Gulf Shores because we
just love the beach the adults can relax
and visit and the kids have plenty to do
don't get bored you know
[Music]
or is the second year in a row that
Arkansas native Jeff Flanagan is
vacationing in Gulf Shores with his
family
it's just where there's water and sand
there's entertainment
Shores Alabama is a bustling tourist
town located along the northern Gulf of
Mexico
it's 32 miles of beaches are famous for
sugary white sand
world-class fishing
and thriving marine life
including
sharks
controlling these waters are the lemon
shark known for its pale yellow hue
the spinner shark that Twirls through
the air to catch its prey
and even the occasional great white the
most feared predator in the ocean
but this coexistence between sharks and
swimmers
can lead to disaster
I've often thought what it would have
been like if we just left the beach a
few minutes earlier but that that wasn't
the way it worked out
Jeff is playing in the ocean with his
seven-year-old grandson Trenton
he was searching around for shells and I
was doing the same thing
the water was up to my waist and it was
up to his chest and it was pretty murky
water
it was getting later in the day and
everybody had had been playing hard and
we're getting tired and we were pretty
close to wrapping it up five more
minutes
but they stay a little longer
a decision Jeff will come to regret
I was also watching the swells and I
could actually see fish in the swells
that were moving through
and I was thinking something must be
hunting for these fish because they're
jumping a lot suddenly Jeff sees a
shadow charged through the waves
and it reminded me of a torpedo moving
through the water just really a fast
almost a blur
I thought to myself that's really big
and no sooner had that thought formed
than Trenton said Papa something's got
my foot
a large shark has Trenton in its jaws
I looked over at him to see what he what
he was talking about and saw the
expression on his face and that's when I
first really felt Panic his face was
just twisted up in agony
when I got to him I immediately grabbed
him and lifted him up out of the water
and I could see his foot was just
mangled
Jeff rushes his young grandson to shore
where the extent of the damage becomes
clear
at that point I kind of think we all
went into shock
just because the injury was so severe
and it was so sudden it was sort of the
way a nightmare feels
Trenton has severe injuries to his foot
including a severed artery
he needs help fast
and then it seemed like two seconds The
Shore Patrol were here
at the hospital doctors perform
emergency surgery on the young boy
Trenton survives
and after months of recovery he regains
the use of his foot
I've grown up 17 years and some change
later now and
I remember it like yesterday it's just
something I think of almost every day
and get comments on every day
I've still got people in town they call
me shark bait
despite his traumatic attack
Trenton gets back in the water
the next year we showed up to the beach
same location same spot the first thing
we did was run out there as far as we
could and swim out past our heads
mom freaked out we weren't allowed to go
past our ankles that year
Trenton's gruesome attack makes
headlines around the country
swear in Alabama shark encounters are
incredibly rare
but not here
since the year 2000 nine attacks have
occurred in this state and seven of them
happened at Gulf Shores or nearby
that means more than 60 percent of
Alabama shark attacks took place off
roughly 50 percent of Alabama's coasts
it's a designation no one in this
tourist haven wants I have friends
who've been out on on boogie boards and
stuff and actually fallen on top of
sharks and it is concerning the ocean
it's never not dangerous
why is Gulf Shores a shark attack hot
spot
[Music]
investigators are on the case
Dr Dan Huber of the University of Tampa
believes the first step in solving this
mystery is identifying Trenton's
assailant when we look at Trenton
Martin's attack photos we can see a
significant amount of damage that was
done to a small child's foot we can see
that these marks on the top side of his
foot those are the types of lacerations
that come from the upper jaw of a shark
now if we move over to the next photo
this gives us a picture of the overall
shape of the shark's head
species like black tips tend to be a bit
more pointed at the front of the jaw
while bull or tiger sharks tend to be a
bit flatter at the front of the jaw now
in the case of Trenton it appears that
he was bitten multiple times and that
the shark actually dragged him under the
water and towards the shore this
indicates very very aggressive behavior
and according to Dr Huber there's only
one species that fits the bill and out
of all of the sharks that are present in
the northern Gulf of Mexico this type of
aggressive behavior and the severity of
the cut below Trenton's ankle would tend
to indicate bull shark
bull sharks can grow up to 11 feet long
and weigh up to 500 pounds
they can swim in water as shallow as
three feet and are widely regarded as
one of the most aggressive species of
shark I remember going under the water
and started to try to kick it and it
just kind of aggressively took me
towards Shore why did the bull shark
strike out at Trenton a detail from the
attack provides a vital clue I felt a
school of fish rush me just prior to
when Trenton was bit by the shark I
noticed that there were a lot of fish
jumping around and there was a lot of
activity
it's not the fish themselves but the
water those fish were swimming in that
Trenton thinks might be Key Water was
different it was murky I do believe that
shark couldn't recede so it hit the
white bottom of my foot thinking it was
a fish
could murky water be the reason behind
Trenton's attack
Dr Huber takes a closer look
Predators follow prey so the fact that
Trenton saw Bait fish jumping out of the
water is a good indication that sharks
were hunting on those Bait fish in the
area at the time of his attack
sharks used their eyesight when
searching for prey but their Vision
works best when the ocean is clear
murky water can significantly reduce the
distance over which sharks can see
objects in the water around them so the
fact that there was murky water at the
time of Trenton's attack means that the
shark may not have been able to see
Trenton quite as easily and therefore
may have attacked him without actually
realizing
this is possible anytime or place that
the sea is murky
like after a storm or in an estuary
for this reason Marine experts advise
beachgoers worldwide to avoid swimming
in cloudy water
the presence of bait fish in murky water
was definitely a contributing factor to
Trenton's attack
but when it comes to explaining why Gulf
Shores is a shark attack Hot Spot
something doesn't add up
there are murky Waters along many parts
of the Alabama coast
and yet sharks disproportionately attack
here
something makes this area unique
but what
nine years after Trenton's terrifying
incident
a shark attacks the swimmer off Gulf
Shores once again
we grew up coming to the beach and
especially after we were a little older
and had our own children every year we
come to Gulf Shores and plan our family
vacation
Louisiana native Laura P has been
visiting the Alabama coast for more than
four decades
but one vacation that started out like
all the rest nearly ended in disaster
I've never been worried or concerned up
until that point that there were some
sharks possibly in the Gulf
[Music]
we woke up to not so good weather it was
a rainy day very very overcast
about two o'clock or so it looked like
the weather was clearing up
Laura hits the beach with her
stepdaughter Jean-Marie
we swim out in the water in Gulf Shores
when you walk out you go through like a
little trough
it was right in that area that I was
walking and was probably about thigh
Deep in water
but as she walks
Laura is suddenly stopped in her tracks
her left ankle is in the jaws of a shark
that moment was just so scary that it
happened so fast it reminded me of one
of those metal traps like a clamp
it was just that sudden and sharp a hard
hard impact
I knew it was a shark and then I knew I
had to get away from it Laura makes a
break for sure
I turned around to come back in and I
had that foot still up in the air
but her escape attempt fails
she feels another sharp pain
it's time on her heel at that point I
was concerned I didn't want it to bite
me again
defends herself
started kicking in the direction that I
thought the shark might be in
at some point I yelled to my daughter
I heard a scream that cut off and I
started looking around
she was screaming for help she needed
help to get out of the water I took off
running down the beach I was still in
about thy deep water so I just kind of
laid on my back when I got to her I
asked her to pull her foot up so I could
look at it
I didn't know what the damage was
I just knew I had to get out of the
water
at that point then it really started to
hurt
once we got on Shore grabbed the biggest
beach towel we had wrapped it up super
tight
that's why I noticed that there was also
wounds to the underside of her foot
basically looked like it was using her
Achilles as floss
I was very in shock about what happened
I just wanted to get help
to an urgent care center where she
received 17 stitches
but her fighting Spirit remains intact I
was scared to go back in the water very
scared
the water is really really important to
me I love being out in the gulf and I
wasn't going to let this stop me from
enjoying the beach and enjoying the
water
foreign is just one of seven beachgoers
who have been attacked in or near Gulf
Shores since the year 2000.
more shark encounters occur along this
small stretch of beach than throughout
all of Alabama
the question is why
locals and tourists alike demand answers
it seems like the sharks are getting
more Bryson
seems like we see more of them
to determine the species that attacked
Laura
Dr Dan Huber performs a bite mark
analysis
[Music]
Laura's bite photos give us some
evidence about the size of the shark
that attacked her but not the species of
shark the detector what we can see is
that the teeth from the upper jaw sank
into the area of her leg just above her
ankle on the back side of her foot and
in the teeth of the lower jaw sank into
the sole of her foot so I would estimate
that this is probably something around a
five foot shark
based on the usual culprits around Gulf
Shores we would expect this to be either
a bull shark or a black tip shark
that means it's likely that multiple
types of sharks are responsible for the
incidents in this area
train and Laura were not necessarily
bitten by the same species of shark
which widens the investigation into
these attacks
in search of Clues investigators examine
the marine environment around the Gulf
of Mexico
and a dark incident from its past
on April 20th 2010 two days before Earth
Day there was an explosion at the deep
water Horizon oil rig
it impacted ocean ecosystem Coastal
ecosystem human health basically
everything in that area
devastating event killed 11 people
and poured more than 134 million gallons
of oil into the sea
becoming one of the worst environmental
disasters in the gulf's history
[Music]
well Mexico has an unfortunate history
of oil spills because of all of the oil
drilling that happens in the northern
Gulf of Mexico in particular we had the
Deepwater Horizon oil spill in 2010.
it's difficult to say exactly what the
long-term effects of these oil spills
are on marine life what we do know is
that sharks have been found with
petroleum in their body tissues
scientists are just beginning to
understand how disasters like oil spills
affect sharks
but we don't necessarily know exactly
how this is going to affect sharks over
time and what we need to do is to
monitor populations year after year
after year to understand the long-term
effects of this toxicity but what
experts do know is that the oil spill
didn't just affect sharks it also
affected their prey
in the wake of the disaster the
commercial fishing industry was
shuttered this commercial fishing ban
allowed local bait fish populations to
bounce back in large numbers and this
newfound abundance may have attracted
hungry Predators due to commercial
fishing being shut down the increase in
Bait fish actually increased shark
populations in this area
sharks have made a great rebound from
years ago where there wasn't near as
many sharks compared to where we're at
now
I can see on my Sonar sometimes that
there's sharks down there
and increase fish and therefore shark
populations
putting beachgoers like Trenton and
Laura into Harm's Way it seems the
answer comes down to timing pollution
oil spills toxic chemicals might have
attributed to some of the movement of
sharks
the deep water Horizon oil spill
occurred off the coast of Louisiana
and the entire Alabama coast was
impacted by this catastrophic event too
[Music]
but many of the Gulf Shores attacks
happened long before the Deepwater
Horizon explosion and oil spill
and the rest occurred a year or more
after
[Music]
but one thing this Theory does prove is
that sharks are attracted to areas with
a high concentration of prey could the
movements of bait fish be important in a
different way
another shocking attack off the coast of
Gulf Shores provides a new lead
foreign
things we deal with are jellyfish stings
you deal with Stingray incidences where
people step near them or step on them
and they get struck
as Chief of Staff of Gulf Shores fire
and Emergency Services Melvin Shepard
responds to incidents of beachgoer
distress
including shark attacks
some of the events we've had is just
exploratory bite once it bit it figured
it was something it wanted to to eat so
it came back and bit again but one
particularly gruesome emergency call
stands out in Melvin's memory
a group of four people had came down to
the beach to train for upcoming
Triathlon when they got to the beach
that morning the winds were coming out
of the South water was rough and choppy
one of the males decided that the water
was a little bit too rough for him to
swim so he decided to stay on the beach
the other three had decided that they
were going to go out and test the waters
and make sure it was actually safe for
other swimmers
among the swimmers is a 44 year old male
so as I got out about 100 yards Neck
Deep Water they began their swim
moments later the triathlete feels a
sudden blow
[Music]
unsure of what just hit him
the swimmer knows he's in trouble his
report was that it literally lifted him
up out of the water
once he regained his posture in the
water he began Treading Water looked
around he didn't see anything
that's when he saw the shark coming at
him
he screamed for his friends to get out
of the water the shark bumped him
if it did so it removed for the fingers
from his right hand
[Music]
he tried to hold his hand up out of the
water to try and prevent blood from
getting in the water but it was to no
avail
the shark came back hit him in the
stomach
he started crying for help
the shark came back it bit a hold of his
right arm up to about his elbow
at that point he knew he's in trouble
's arm still in its jaw
and hauls him across the bottom of the
ocean
when the shark dragged him along the sea
floor it actually drug him towards Shore
so drag him into shallower water to
where he could stand up at that point he
was able to fight the shark by hitting
it with his left arm
and pulling his right arm free
the critically injured swimmer somehow
makes it back to the beach
but the shark's reign of terror isn't
over
charges at one of the other triathletes
biting him a little the man is able to
fight off the predator and swim to shore
the injuries of the first victim are
extensive they fashioned a tourniquet
out of a shirt onto his right arm to
help prevent blood loss
paramedics found him said that he willed
himself to stay awake during this entire
ordeal his claim was he wanted to stay
awake until he could see his family and
let him know that he was okay and that
he loved them
despite the horrific encounter the
swimmers survives
the second victim escapes with minor
puncture wounds to his hip and arm
the terrifying double attack leaves
beachgoers rattled and prompts officials
to take action
right after the incident occurred local
authorities did close all the beaches in
Alabama from the state line of Florida
and Alabama to the tip of Fort Morgan
while they were doing that biologists
were flying in helicopters looking for
sharks in the waters
aerial surveillance fails to locate the
shark
was from the Attack lead investigators
to believe a six-foot bull shark was
responsible
there's a lot of shock that this
happened it was the first reported shark
attack to this magnitude in Alabama
the day after the incident the beaches
were reopened even though the beaches
were packed with it being a mid-june day
many people didn't venture out into the
water and those that did stay very
shallow
emotions were very high as to what
occurred
these triathletes are two of the seven
victims attacked since the year 2000 in
waters around Gulf Shores Alabama
a small Beach town that accounts for
more than 60 percent of attacks in the
state
[Music]
but why is this Coastline such a shark
attack hot spot
Chief Shepherd has a theory of his own
the pier you see behind me it is a very
well-known
fishing spot
a lot of locals visit the pier yearly
tourists come down and fish from the
pier
especially the summer months we have a
lot of fishermen not only the pier but
along the beach as well
[Music]
Gulf Shores is one of the country's
Premier fishing locations
its flourishing Waters lure Anglers with
the promise of an epic catch and walking
away empty-handed is rare but this
fishing fervor may have unintended
consequences
they are using lot bait
which could promote sharks coming into
the area
yeah I've seen sharks I've seen them
over at the fishing pier behind us they
like the bay
could bait draw sharks closer to shore
putting them in direct contact with
humans
sharks are opportunistic when they eat
so as if fish is being reeled in on the
line it's flailing the Sharks pick that
up and they go after that
we get a fish on the line and the
Anglers struggling to reel to fish up
because it's a good fish and the shark
says oh well there's there's dinner
right there let's go ahead and get a
hold of him because it's an easy catch
for the shark
this opportunistic feeding is known to
local Anglers as the shark attacks
but scientists refer to it as
depredation
depredation is the partial or complete
removal of a hooked species by a
non-target species so in our part of the
world most commonly we're talking about
a depredated red snapper for example and
typically the culprit here in the north
central Gulf of Mexico is a shark
growing up to 50 pounds red snapper are
a popular offering at seafood markets
and restaurants they are found in such
abundance here that Alabama is known as
the red snapper capital of the world
but Anglers can only hook these fish
during a certain time of the year
our season for the red snapper takes two
days and our main targeted days are from
June 1st to around August 2nd
red snapper season
the majority of the attacks that
occurred near Gulf Shores took place
during this time period
could red snapper season explain why
Gulf Shores is at the epicenter of so
many shark attacks
investigators are on the verge of
discovering answers
there's evidence showing that sharks can
become behaviorally conditioned to our
fishing activities
conditioning is the way in which sharks
learn that a particular set of cues such
as a fishing pole or Pier can lead to
being fed
sharks will show up in particular areas
which are known fishing hot spots
because when people are trying to reel
and fish that makes an easy meal for a
shark
Research indicates sharks can remember
this Association for an impressive
length of time
at least a year
that means they'll keep returning to
these hot spots over and over again
will that fishing activity
area of Gulf Shores could be a
contributing factor to the spike in
attacks
[Music]
proximity to popular fishing spots seems
like a viable hypothesis but there's a
problem when the data is analyzed it
turns out that not all of the victims
were attacked in close vicinity to a
fishing pier
perhaps the answer lies not deep in the
sea
but rather high in the clouds
a detail from Laura's attack holds a
clue
we woke up to not so good weather it was
a rainy day very very overcast and a
heavy rainy day
rainfall how might this seemingly
insignificant weather pattern help to
explain the attacks
Dr Marcus dryman continues the
investigation
mobile
is the city in the United States that
experiences the most rainfall
located just an hour's Drive Northwest
of Gulf Shores mobile sees around 66
inches of rainfall annually
almost double the national average
and most of this precipitation also
reaches the Coast
Mobile Bay is a region Gulf Shores
Alabama are regions that experience lots
and lots and lots of rainfall
to understanding the spike
because storms could create an ecosystem
that is optimal for one particular type
of shark
the same species that is implicated in a
majority of the Gulf Shores attacks
oh
it makes for an ecosystem that not very
many species can thrive in you have to
have a certain tolerance for changes in
salinity and the bull shark is one of
those species that can do really well
in widely dynamic salinities
Dr dryman's research assistant Amanda
Jefferson demonstrates the way in which
rain impacts the salinity in the sea
this is just plain queer sea water
to measure salinity we use a simple
meter with a salinity probe right now
the salinity in this tank is about 35
parts per thousand the salinity of
typical seawater
now I'm going to fill a speaker with
some fresh water to add to our
experiment tank
going to be adding some blue dye to it
to distinguish it from the clear salt
water in this tank
in this experiment the fresh water
represents rain and as Amanda adds it to
the tank it completely transforms the
composition of the sea water
adding fresh water gives us a new
salinity of about 23 parts per thousand
representing brackish water or a mix of
salt and fresh water
it's a change that could have happened
on the day of Laura's attack
because as it turns out rainfall in Gulf
Shores is heaviest in the summertime
the same season in which most of the
incidents occurred
that rainfall very simply put acts to
reduce the salinity in those near-shore
Coastal environments
when the salinity is lowered in the
coastal regions it creates a habitat
that's hospitable for a species like a
bull shark
are conditions created by storms and
Gulf Shores attracting bull sharks to
the shallows and causing the attacks
Dr Dan Huber examines the data
Trend and Laura were attacked right off
the coast of Gulf Shores where there
would have been lowered salinity during
the summer months making it an ideal
habitat for bull sharks
but there was also a triathlete who was
attacked at a distance offshore
in normal Marine salinity so decreased
salinity is not the only factor that can
contribute to the spike in attacks in
Gulf Shores
perhaps what makes this area so
attractive to sharks is not a natural
phenomenon but rather something man-made
could people unintentionally be putting
themselves at risk
[Music]
Dr Sean Powers researches the Ecology of
coastal Fisheries throughout the Gulf
[Music]
and he's found this area has a very
distinct topography
[Music]
most of Alabama and most of the Gulf of
Mexico in the shallow Waters is just
sand and mud
there's very little relief so it's just
a flat desert essentially an ocean
desert is an unattractive landscape for
fish because it gives them nowhere to
hide from predators
there is a solution to this problem
one of the things we learned about 50
years ago was that if we deploy these
types of artificial Reef structures that
we can attract fish
so the state decided to essentially
deploy artificial reefs in Shallow
Waters so that the fishermen had more
access to the fish
artificial reefs are man-made structures
that mimic the functions of natural
Coral formations and Alabama has roughly
15 000 of them
when the Rave hits the bottom starts
getting the algae on it and then the
smaller fish kind of show up then it
becomes the fish eat and Fish World you
got the big fish eating smaller fish and
the bigger fish eating the big fish and
it just becomes part of the food chain
from there
and this food chain
all the way to the top
just as fish are attracted to these
structures the sharks are attracted to
the fish
see more and more sharks around the
artificial structures are the artificial
reefs of Alabama attracting hungry
sharks
putting vacationers in danger
if you're increasing the attractiveness
of the area to sharks then yes there's a
potential that more sharks could
encounter the population on the beach
in the case of Gulf Shores it seems
there's one more factor to consider
Alabama's artificial reefs are located
roughly 30 to 60 miles offshore
and the attacks occurred much closer to
the beach
bin suggested that the presence of these
artificial reefs could be a contributing
factor to the spike in attacks in Gulf
Shores Alabama however the artificial
reefs are too far offshore to have
brought sharks into any proximity with
beachgoers in Gulf Shores so the
presence of these artificial reefs is
not a contributing factor to the spike
in attacks
but a key takeaway from this theory is
that the underwater landscape of Gulf
Shores is unique
so perhaps this Topography is important
in another way
one common denominator in some of the
attacks stands out
we're up on this Sandbar where the good
shells are it was to where you could
walk a good distance out into the water
and still be pretty shallow
as I was stepping
troughton coming back up on the shallow
part is when I actually felt the
SharkBite
shallow Coastal Waters
according to Dr Marcus dryman
understanding which sharks frequent
these areas May unlock why they are
attacking
we've done a lot of survey work in this
area so we have a really good idea of
the species composition which sharks are
there and what size and what sex of the
sharks are there
Dr dryman's research reveals a common
characteristic among these inshore
inhabitants
their age
we do see relatively High abundance of
juveniles of some species
for example black tip sharks bull sharks
so we know that these habitats are good
primary nurseries
if you think about the things that are
really important to a young freshly born
shark things like protection from
predators ample prey resources just the
right mix of environmental conditions
things like temperature and salinity and
dissolved oxygen the north central Gulf
of Mexico has all of those things could
the presence of nurseries explain why
Gulf Shores is the shark attack capital
of Alabama
history suggests it's possible
in 2018 in New York
two children were bitten by sharks on
the same day
experts believe inexperienced juvenile
sharks searching for food
may have mistakenly bitten the swimmers
is the same thing happening at Gulf
Shores
we know that it creates increased
opportunities for those sharks to
mistakenly and accidentally interact
with beachgoers particularly during the
summer months when there's lots and lots
of folks in the water lots of bait fish
in the near shore environment and it
does increase the chance that there's
going to be an interaction between a
shark and a beachgoer
but one detail doesn't add up
juvenile sharks have nurseries in
multiple locations along the Alabama
coast not just Gulf Shores
something else is going on
perhaps the answer is found not at the
beginning of the marine life cycle but
rather at the end
investigators hone in on a devastating
Marine phenomenon
one that can transform a thriving
environment
into a wasteland
history behind Gulf Shores Alabama being
a shark attack hotspot
focuses in on a phenomenon that begins
with rainfall but not just in Gulf
Shores Nationwide the rain that falls
across 31 different states eventually
drains into the Mississippi River
this is called the Mississippi watershed
and it's where this Watershed culminates
that may be key to the investigation all
of the rainfall that lands on any point
of this Watershed eventually ends up
right here in the Gulf of Mexico
that means roughly four and a half
million gallons of water per second is
discharged into the Gulf every day
and it isn't just H2O
that rainfall runoff contains a lot of
nutrients from agriculture Urban
Development Wastewater overflows all of
that coming into one area
the nutrients cause algae blooms that
grow like crazy usually in summer months
between June and August
when these algae blooms die or decompose
they remove oxygen from the water column
causing something called a dead zone
dead zone is the common name for hypoxia
an area of low to no oxygen
patches of oxygen deprived water occur
across the globe
but they can be particularly devastating
in the Gulf
what you're seeing right here with the
red orange and yellow is the outline of
the hypoxic Zone this Zone can be as big
as the state of Delaware
it's the second largest Dead Zone in the
world
how does this phenomenon impact sharks
in the waters of Alabama
sharks they have certain little sweet
spots so to speak of temperature and
salinity and dissolved oxygen that they
really prefer
but what we know is that when conditions
change and become more preferable
outside of their usual habitats these
are highly mobile species highly
migratory species so they can very
easily move from one area to another
could The Dead Zone Off Louisiana
push sharks to seek out oxygen-rich
water elsewhere
like off the coast of Gulf Shores
the timing of the attacks seems to
support this Theory the one consistent
factor that they all have in common is
that they were bitten during summer
months
several months when The Dead Zone in the
Gulf of Mexico was present
so it's very possible that sharks are
consistently avoiding this area going
into Gulf Shores where we had lots of
bait fish and
lots of sharks
[Music]
could check out
it's possible that the dead zone could
cause sharks to flee East from Louisiana
towards Gulf Shores
better is that we don't have Data
Tracking sharks during these specific
events so we really don't know where the
Sharks went
experts are unable to pin the spike on
the strong Dead Zone in the Gulf
there's one final Avenue to explore
[Music]
each year more people come here they
stay here longer a lot of it just has to
do with the beauty of the Gulf Coast of
Alabama People
could this be the final piece to the
puzzle
why people love fishing out of gulf
shores along with the Sandy white
beaches
Gulf Shores is consistently ranked by
tourism websites as the number one beach
in all of Alabama
each year nearly 70 million visitors
descend upon the Alabama coast
and the majority visit during the summer
months
the same season in which most of the
attacks have taken place
[Music]
is Gulf Shores popularity also its
downfall
when I hear the Gulf Shores is the shark
attack capital of Alabama the first
thing I think about are awesome beaches
on Barrier Islands this is where people
go to spend their recreational time so
it makes sense that wherever the humans
are most highly concentrated that's
where we're going to find the spike and
shark attacks because the single most
telling factor in the entire history of
shark attacks is human behavior wherever
there are more people we find more shark
attacks
[Music]
yet for many tourists including Trenton
and Laura the beauty of Gulf Shores is
well worth the risk
after this incident I've been back to
the beach many times
the first few times that I went back out
in the water I was very very nervous
constantly looking around there are
times I go out in the water now and I
don't even I don't even think about it I
love the beach I love the water
I put an end to the whole fear I just
live and you learn you just pay
attention don't
don't be scared though
[Music]
foreign